The primary funding source of this program is
just people, good people like you, I'm sure,
who go to join Pacman dot com and sign up for a
membership. Hey, this is very, very interesting.
Now that the entire Hunter Biden story from the
New York Port Post has been very much called into
question, Media Eye is reporting that Fox News
was actually approached with the story before The
New York Post or at least concurrently, and could
have made a decision to run it as soon as or even
earlier than The New York Post. And of course,
it was Donald Trump's henchman, Rudy Giuliani,
who approached them with the Hunter Biden story.
The story. It turns out, was too crazy and too
incredible and too poorly sourced for Fox News
to go with it. Fox News reportedly looked at
the story, realized that they couldn't vet the
sourcing, they couldn't vet the veracity of the
emails, and they passed on it. And on it went to
The New York Post. And there's a few different
interesting layers here to talk about. Now, first
of all, just because Fox News didn't publish it
doesn't mean they haven't promoted it. And in
fact, Fox News has been going crazy with the
story. But the idea was Fox News because The New
York Post was the original source on the story,
can talk about it not as their reporting, but
just as here is what the New York Post story
says. And it kind of puts a let a layer between
them and the story while still allowing them to
talk about it. So understand how far this has
gone so far from the original story. Originally,
The New York Post reports it trumpets say it's
a bombshell, but it seems a little bit fishy,
contains things that were previously debunked,
like it again raises the idea that Joe Biden
was involved in the firing of a prosecutor in
Ukraine because Hunter Biden asked him to do it
in his role as a board member of the Ukrainian
energy company Berrys MMA. That was debunked
and a bunch of other elements were
debunked. And it sort of looked like, wow,
if these emails are real. It seems like Joe Biden
loves his son. That was one of the big takeaways.
We then learned that the reporter who wrote
the story primarily wrote the story, didn't
even want his name on it because it was so shaky
and that other New York Post staffers says to take
my name off of the story. I don't even want my
byline on there. I don't even think we should be
publishing this story at all. It's kind of weird.
Then we hear that Rudy Giuliani says, well, yeah,
it is a 50/50 shot that he worked on the story
with a Russian spy. And then now we learn that
Fox News, of all places, decided it was below them
to publish the story. And even some people on air
at Fox News Channel have said the story's a little
weird. Check out, for example, what Chris Wallace
said about it and about Rudy Giuliani as well.
You know, I can understand the concern
about this story. It is completely unverified. And
frankly, Rudy Giuliani is not the most reliable
source anymore. I hate to say that, but it's
just true. There's a story in The Washington
Post and The New York Times today saying that
that national security adviser Robert O'Brien
had to tell the president in December of last
year that the intelligence agencies thought that
Giuliani was being worked by Russian agents and
was being used to spread Russian disinformation.
That is Fox News anchor Chris Wallace
saying this. But again, just as a reminder,
Fox News isn't off the hook here. Fox News
has been talking about the story constantly.
Their top primetime opinion, people have
had no qualms whatsoever about spreading
this story as if it's true. Despite it being less
credible with every single passing day so great,
Fox didn't publish it, that they reported on it.
They just needed or wanted a degree of separation.
And the plausible deniability that comes with
saying, as reported by The New York Post,
they didn't want to break the story. But since The
New York Post did, they can say something along
the lines of, well, we we don't peep. This is
what is being reported. And as a final reminder,
News Corp owns both Fox News and The New York
Post. Now, I'm not alleging that, for example,
one if one was more conspiratorial, they
might say they may have coordinated Fox
News and The New York Post, both under News
Corp, might have made the decision. Listen,
this is better if The New York Post reports it
and then Fox News can run with it rather than
Fox News reporting it. It'll be better received,
that rebel letter. Maybe that happened. Maybe
it didn't happen. But the point is, Fox News has
been signal boosting it. They've had no hesitation
whatsoever to do it. And when there's this
much vertical integration, media consolidation,
anything could be going on. And in the end, News
Corp published it and News Corp continues to
signal boost. On two of their different platforms,
every single day, it becomes less credible.